à l'extérieur de l'hôpital universitaire
d'état d'haïti la radio annonce
l'itinéraire des prochaines
manifestations
pendant ce temps à l'intérieur on
continue de traiter les blessés et
autres victimes de dix jours de
violences entre jeunes et une justine
hommes veillent sur sa fillette d'à
peine un mois et demi giuly ni car hélas
inhalé du gaz lacrymogène lors d'un
affrontement soudés entre policiers et
manifestants survenus tout près d'elle
alors qu'elle marchait simplement dans
la rue dès lundi à caussens la petite
est vite devenu in her qu elle ne
pouvait même pas pleurer pour libérer
ses voies respiratoires
la docteure jessica lim on rassure la
maman inquiète qui n'a même pas les
moyens de se payer les médicaments
nécessaires dirige l'hôpital il nous
entraîne ensuite vers la salle d'urgence
à moitié vide
normalement elles débordent on est
inconfortable comme médecin qui a une
mission de soigner parce que vous
arrivez pas
à accueillir des gens et c'est bon
patients médecins infirmières ne pouvait
pas se rendre à l'établissement depuis
quelques jours en raison des routes
barrées par les manifestations
une pénurie d'eau et de pétrole guette
maintenant l'hôpital faute de livraisons
vous avez suffisamment interview
quelques jours pas vous quelque chose
donc on ne voit pas bleu dans 72 ans
trouve un le système de santé en manque
de fournitures et des personnels même
avant le soulèvement populaire atteint
désormais un point de rupture
une femme han douleur lancent des cris
stridents
evelyne saint-just gît sur le bitume
alors qu'il fait 33 degrés à l'extérieur
s'apprête à accoucher
aucun médecin ne vient l'aider son cas
n'est pas jugé prioritaire
on ne veut pas l'admettre tant que la
tête du bébé ne sera pas sorti se désole
la soeur d'événements
et puis pendant qu'une ambulance arriver
attire l'attention médicale
l'impensable se produit yveline
saint-just donne naissance à un bébé
dans le stationnement entre deux
véhicules
entouré de passants qui ne savent pas
comment l'aider